so I feel like we very casually brushed
over the fact that you saw a demon and
in this house there's an older man he
shot himself in my room and in your room
I was not told that that's true I
purposely didn't tell you until you were
here thank you
[Music]
so we're gonna call right now we're on
our way to Casper Wyoming to see the
clips the modes finally gonna defeat the
Sun right now you know hotel rooms cost
seventy thousands of dollars I asked on
Twitter if I had any fans in Wyoming
we're not just staying in a fan we're
staying in a teen fans bedroom Eugene is
in New York for wedding Ned is also
seeing the Eclipse in Portland he's in
Oregon Oregon
he's glamping glamping glamping glamping
- glamping oh my goodness also very
special guest joining us on the tripod
today
this is the last trip you're taking as a
not married couple yeah that's right
that's why we brought you to keep us
virgins till the wedding day
[Music]
we were spitting out air because we went
through a tunnel and mid wishes Aurora
what are these
we made you these things and this one is
they seems super nice seems super nice
all right well here we are in our room
the three of us just like room readers
Sarita so my a my in this one this is my
roommate right here wow these are the
glasses what are you doing are you
finally made it to the top tell this
monkey Rock I don't really see it really
looks like a dick from down below can't
even wrap my hand around it man don't
you speak his name in this house I'm
looking at the other cat the cat's
looking at me it's a nice moment
oh yeah that's the last of that button
of the beach ball winter hat stickers oh
we have a new aspiration Church but this
is a good wall this is also building
this applies at the end of this wow this
is stuff you cannot buy you look great
in this purple light look good
where's Aurora she's over there she's
gonna spider Aurora told me that there
is a dead little girl that lives in a
room wait I'm sorry Emily I'm sorry hey
can you come here for a second please
part of rumor heard a rumor that your
house is haunted yeah it's over 100
years old TVs but no it's not the house
I don't know I wouldn't expect that it's
not me it's her they stay with Aurora
because she has this really great energy
around her I'm sorry we need to tell the
story this is a cool place to do it
there's an older man he shot himself in
my room polio do you think we can get
Ryan to do some voiceover for this I
gotta say this one really gives me the
creeps
it's not fun
not fun a child time I'm not stoked
there no huh cut stoked but everyone
seems to want to hear about it so here
we go
built in 1912 the house was owned by a
family there was a little girl in the
family named Emily and she died of polio
she was like 4 and I am an imaginary
friend named Emily who died no horsin
that's pretty cool
I just got the first theory is that the
house is haunted by the ghosts of
previous residents perhaps the owners or
even more horrifying
Emily my door in the room they're saying
it opens and closes I have tons of
videos I've been just opening closed
event so can you can you show us that
it's gonna [ __ ] open no I want to
point out that she did mention the door
was actually latched to me that's
impressive
I don't think that was latched well she
said it was oh well and so now you're
calling her a liar yeah I'm calling her
a liar well that's [ __ ] up that's okay
Oh God Keith's right old houses are
built very poorly mind you true but that
doesn't mean a doorknobs gonna move by
itself can we zoom in on the knob and
see that knob turn it looks latch to me
that does not look latched okay but
she's a liar and being said the house
has been subject to some other strange
and unexplainable phenomenon she has
scratches oh yeah I get scratches on my
back when I'd like just in there
all these believers always getting
scratches that's all that's what demons
do it's not me eczema which brings us to
theory to Emily is in fact a demon and
the house is not a case of a haunting
but instead listen like put blood on
paper in your name and then also the
same girl who drove around for an entire
summer with Ouija board in her car yeah
that's where I got the demon I was
completely blown away it was only like
midnight and I was in the bathroom and I
turned around from facing the shower and
I saw a really tall figure wearing one
of those big heads and I was like holy
[ __ ] he looked like that being said
let's turn to period 3 you do love cats
she does live with cats whatever the
explanation is clear Aurora's house is a
hotbed of activity but whether or not
the house is definitively haunted will
remain unsolved can one of you just like
Wiis to complete this as a cat fuzzy
get it off of me wonder how that
happened
[Music]
I don't know it could have been anything
Keith all right well let's go right for
bad
so we're alone and in a teenager's
bedroom should we explore yeah let's
explore the poster of back in time Keith
on the walls Aurora's band participation
like this is who do you think we look
like and also she has a good sense of
humor that's what my son would look like
we I wish oh my god get off the pit pop
figurines I guess this is a Christmas
present posing sexily let's say I'm just
and we're gonna have to blur Oh almost
all that please y'all play with teams
I'm gonna say hey demons they're
inviting you they're taunting you and
they're demons
it's me your boy I like 10 you like the
girl from the ring you own the venom
like crawl like a spider lady yes a good
excuse
we're getting ready for bed and I got a
cat I'm a leg
I got a cab the floor and I got cats in
my heart I'm in heaven
okay well tomorrow's eclipse so let's
Eclipse our eyes of the islands it is
the morning and the Eclipse has begun
yet I was so slightly
it's starting you can look right at the
Sun without any protection at all
you know just to flamethrower just a
fire-breathing horse nothing to see here
let's move on oh my god there's a cat on
a leash things are different here Jenny
Lee accepts anything can happen if you
get powers you get powers then that guy
you just saw he was a four year old well
how it has arrived it's like a little
fingernail it's so cool guys
[Applause]
[Applause]
transcendent edible the most crazy
it was ooze you can't go back to a
regular moon after that we had a lot of
fun here in Casper Wyoming laws for
hands i nipples are not that like
they're like ketchup bottles and it was
I guess I'm part of her artistic drawing
shop you have to remember don't forget
the magic thing we've ever seen you have
to remember it forever that's it so
we'll see thanks for what do you what do
you think what would you put the haunted
meter
how many ghouls would you give this out
of ten I'm gonna give it zero zero okay
that's harsh so you can overuse out of
ten I felt like this one had a piece of
video evidence that was somewhat
compelling if it's door opening sure I'm
a lil flabbergasted by your rating I
think Webber coasted oh my god put it on
a shirt don't I find him thanks Zack
maybe one ghoul without the sheet cool
look like under a sheet one day one time
at Disneyland I saw that the Mickey
Mouse character take his head off what
did he look like look like a guy he kind
of look like you was that you from the
future did you come back despite me as a
kid maybe